[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
budget rectificatif 2022 le Sénat en
première ligne pour soutenir les
Français
inflation à 6% hausse des prix de
l'énergie comment continuer à protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français et
renforcer les infrastructures du
quotidien sur l'ensemble du territoire
dans un contexte conjoncturel difficile
le deuxième projet de loi de finance
rectificative pour 2022 déposez le 2
novembre visé à financer des mesures qui
pourraient bénéficier rapidement et
directement aux Français
député et sénateurs sont parvenus à un
compromis sur ce texte lors de la
commission mixte paritaire réunit le 22
novembre au Sénat l'accord confirme
l'ensemble des moyens permettant de
protéger les Français contre le niveau
élevé de l'inflation avec le déploiement
d'un chèque énergie exceptionnel la
prolongation de la remise carburant le
soutien à l'achat de pellets et de
bûches de bois ou encore la prorogation
en 2023 de l'éligibilité à ma prime
rénov sans condition de ressources pour
des travaux de rénovation globale
le Sénat a marqué de toute son empreinte
cet accord parlementaire
ainsi député et sénateurs ont conservé
plusieurs ouvertures de crédit adoptées
par le Sénat dans l'objectif d'accentuer
les moyens dédiés aux infrastructures
sur tout le territoire
50 millions d'euros seront par exemple
débloqués pour la réfection des ponts et
du réseau routier notamment des petites
communes c'est aussi le Sénat qui a
souhaité qu'une aide exceptionnelle soit
accordée aux agences de l'eau compte
tenu des défis induits par l'épisode de
sécheresse de l'été dernier le compromis
conserve également le soutien à l'action
des maisons France service à hauteur de
12,5 millions d'euros soulageant ainsi
le budget des petites collectivités
enfin dans un objectif de sincérité
budgétaire et de maîtrise de la dépense
la commission mixte paritaire à diminuer
de 2 milliards d'euros le déficit
budgétaire de l'État en réduisant des
crédits non utilisés sous l'impulsion du
Sénat
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]